the vessel called safer has been
murdered off Yemen's Coast for 30 years
but maintenance on the tanker carrying
more than a million barrels of oil
stopped when the Civil War began in
2015.
experts warned that an oil spill of that
magnitude would wipe out one of the
world's largest marine ecosystems as the
rusting safer tanker could have ruptured
or exploded the a man intricately
involved in the operation to transfer
the oil to a replacement tanker explains
the achievement
after eight years of waiting and two
years of intense work
the global Community Has Come Together
through 23 member states of the United
Nations
through the private sector and the
global public to achieve a significant
milestone
Salvage Crews operated for 18 days amid
High summer temperatures and strong
currents to offload the oil from The
Vessel it's an operation that had to
navigate both treacherous Waters and a
fragmented and divided political
environment we undertook this operation
in the midst of a conflict Zone
including floating sea mines still in
the area where we had to navigate with
the vessels and with a replacement
tanker the successful conclusion of the
operation a world first comes as a great
relief to the teams who worked on the
Monumental task
this is a major disaster averted it was
a ticking time bomb as many called it
and it could have destroyed hundreds of
thousands of livelihoods it could have
affected the shipping up the Red Sea
towards the Suez Canal it could have
destroyed biodiversity in Fisheries for
a quarter of a century for years warring
sides involved in Yemen's Civil War
claimed the oil as their own with the
environmental crisis averted attention
now turns to the politically thorny
question of who owns it in the coming
weeks the UN plans to have the crippled
tanker scrapped and recycled mycleple Al
Jazeera